quartier général d' alexandre boulerice
à montréal
si on monte les canadiens que le québec
reste oranje online nos amis en ontario
a gagné dans son local électoral sur le
point d'être inauguré les députés
sortants de rosemont-petite-patrie
rencontre ces nouveaux bénévoles
le joueur étoile du npd demande deuxième
mandat aux électeurs et il a toute la
machine électorale néo démocrates pour
l'appuyer
ici dans rosemont petite patrie on voit
la campagne la mieux financée au québec
on va être capable de dépasser le
maximum pour une prévue par la loi
électorale
on est rendu à soins cent soixante dix
bénévoles ici seul c'est la grosse
différence légende et bartoli depuis une
semaine de ces dix personnes par jour
on accueille qui dit juif devenu un coût
mais un bon jour alexandre boulerice
n'était pas la victoire pour acquis loin
de là il multiplie les rencontres dans
sa circonscription rang des cafés même
en pleine canicule pour solidifier ses
appuis à quelques kilomètres de là à
laval les députés sortant josé munoz
mélo sirote lui aussi son café mais ici
il a un goût plus amer
conclue avec la vague orange soulevé par
l'ancien chef néo démocrate jack layton
il lui est resté fidèle
mais même s'il le souhaitait il ne
pourra pas se présenter à nouveau pour
le npd lors de l'investiture
une autre candidature est ouvert et une
candidate croit-il fortement désiré par
l'exécutif d'un teddy sont allés
chercher une troisième personne une
personne qui a eu lui même pas d'un
conteur d'ong et là vous voyez il y
avait déjà la décision d'aider toit vert
josé nunez mélo n'est pas seul et l'ue à
ne pas avoir été retenu pour défendre à
nouveau les couleurs du npd
trois autres de ses collègues ont perdu
leur investiture et au moins autant
d'aspirants candidats ont été écartés
l'inde est au stratège néo démocrate
proche conseiller de jack layton en 2011
affirme que ce sont les membres qui
choisit ce que c'est la démocratie qui a
parlé surtout que la popularité attire
de bonnes candidatures les députés qui
ont travaillé fort qui ont fait le
travail de terrain ont réussi à
remporter dans les vestiaires pour
certains malheureusement on est en
mesure de garder leur poste
ça arrive mais ça démontre la vitalité
du parti dans son comté aucun électeur
parmi ceux que nous avons rencontrés ne
pouvait identifier leurs députés
est ce que vous connaissez le nom de
votre député à laval 1
son nom au morgan maudite bonne question
josé nunez mélo changerait absolument
pas mais il assure qu'il a bien fait son
travail qu'il a été assidu il affirme
n'avoir manqué qu'une dizaine de votes
en quatre ans il a même déposé un projet
de loi jaeglé dont c'était une personne
à qui vous parliez et vous seriez qu'ils
nous écoutent et il ne me rappelle pas
d'avoir une conversation 2012 le
problème dit il c'est que le parti qui
lui a donné envie de faire de la
politique a changé mayenne avec au
bureau des leaders de l'opposition qui
est assez commune
aux politiques mpo certaine politique
est une chose mais là ça change un peu
la donne
plutôt que de baisser les bras josé
nunez mélo lui a décidé de faire voter
dès son adversaire politique
il a annoncé qu ils joignaient leurs
entre partis vers l'essence d'élaborer
davantage sur cette affaire pour le npd
c'est en quelque sorte un passage obligé
quand on aspire à former le prochain
gouvernement à cause aussi du travail
accompli dans les quatre dernières
années puis à cause aussi de la
possibilité de gagner la prochaine
élection
on a une équipe oui renforcé avec
d'excellents candidats ou candidates
juste refaire le sont ici julie du fun
radio canada québec et pour savoir
exactement qui sont les candidats
déclarés jusqu'à présent dans les trois
cent trente huit circonscriptions du
pays
je vous invite à consulter notre dossier
web à l'adresse que vous voyez en ce
moment à l'écran